PEGI 18
here's a look at the character system in
fallout 4 you do spend a lot of time in
our games looking at your stats looking
at your items and in fallout that comes
to life with your pip-boy here are your
seven specials and these really define
who you are you also have perks which
are skills and abilities you choose when
you level up and here's what it looks
like when you make that choice this is
the perk chart where you can see all the
perks you can select and the ones you
have it is organized by the seven
specials there is a perk for each
special and each rank of that special
from one to ten and if you have the
value you can choose it so if you were
to come out of the vault with a ten
charisma you can pick this intimidation
perk that lets you manipulate and
control other people there are 70 base
perks with multiple ranks that do new
things yielding 275 that you can choose
from and it gives you a ton of choice
and many different ways to develop your
character over the course of the game
it's all up to you
you